At the time I was told I had any rashes to let them know I had a small rash one week, but it went away.
Now, months later, starting in October, the rash came back. I put vinegar on it and it went away again.
In December, it came back. My doctor told me it is a fungus under the skin. It is hard to get rid of.
Okay, so my question right there would be, how do they know that it's a fungus under I would ask I would ask those questions.
You know, is it what tested do they do to come up with that diagnosis that it's a fungus under your skin.
She puts you on this medicated cream. I've used it. It goes away when it comes back as soon as you get back. So because that is a a steroid cream that will decrease the inflammation and will, but it doesn't really deal.
It certainly doesn't kill a fungus. It's certainly not going to deal with anything that is subcutaneous or systemic that's causing it.
So still not dealing with the cause there. I've used it goes away as soon as I cut back on the use.
I looked at the right ringworm program blog.
The suggestion was kelp capsules.
The ringworm, a Google ringworm and look at the images of ringworm because ringworm is very distinct and easy to diagnose by looking at the pictures of ringworm.
It looks like those pictures will then treat it as a ringworm and certainly you could use kelp and run the ringworm program. I would also try some essential oils on it.
I started using vinegar again to keep it from getting worse. I would definitely try some essential oils on it. I would try some grapefruit seed.
Grapefruit seed extract, grapefruit seed extract as a liquid form. You could also take that as a capsule form, but I would look up that rash on some Google images to make sure you're really dealing with what you're dealing with.
I understand and I'm going to talk about some people who submitted some information about lab work. The same is my answer is going to be the same for that the most common cause of some of these things is a medication that you're taking.
If you're on any medications, that is the most common cause for a rash is a medication you're taking, which is a sensitivity to a medication. So many medications affect your metabolic pathways and can cause irritations and histamine disruptions and rashes.
Basically, your body hardly tried to detoxify through your skin so look at that as well. What I'm saying is try to dig to the cause of that.